australian musician and youtube star lil
beau weep has died
[Music]
so much
she was 22 years old the singer's dad
confirmed the sad news on facebook
posting several images of his daughter
whose real name was winona brooks
writing in part quote this weekend we
lost the fight for my daughter's life
against depression trauma ptsd and drug
addiction that we have been fighting
since we got her back from america
through emergency repatriation dfat but
broken
the cause of death has not been revealed
but according to her dad's post the
codependency singer fought hard against
her demons picking up the broken pieces
over and over again but she could not
fight anymore lil bow weeb's dad praised
his daughter writing that he's proud of
her beyond words and added that she is
his hero
[Music]
little bow weave started sharing music
she produced on soundcloud in 2015 and
had since amassed more than 36 000
followers her last post was a short song
titled ptsd
[Music]
and her following was loyal on youtube
too with over
125 000 subscribers
[Applause]
[Music]
in her most recent instagram post on
march 2nd she explained that she was
mourning the anniversary of losing her
unborn child so i've been crying all day
so i'm sorry um but um
around this time last year i lost
my child and i would like to do
something in remembrance of her
preferably spread some flowers
at a beach or
and spend the day just morning
i'd really appreciate if anyone adelaide
would be kind enough to do that for me
and with me
so please reach out thank you in the
caption she expressed her sorrow writing
in part quote i am heavily dosed on
seroquel to avoid any psychosis from my
cptsd
not only have i been mourning my child i
have recently found out my fertility has
been affected by growing up with a
severe eating disorder and before
sharing her emotional video she shared
this pic of her baby bump on february
26th alongside the caption mourning you
[Music]
you